every skill you add to your skill tool
belt makes the rest of your skills more
valuable if you look at Jay-Z maybe
somebody who naturally had Rhythm and so
then all of a sudden he learned how to
rap and then he learned how to promote
oh significantly more valuable and then
he learned how to make a label and then
he learned how to recruit other artists
once he had the label he got
significantly more leverage on the skill
of promotion and he could recognize
people because of his skill in rapping
in Rhythm each of these scale stacks on
top and then eventually he pinnacled
into Beyonce as his top skill I'm just
kidding
where's he going oh and that's why I'm
just like learn the skill find the next
skill